One of the things that I think companies
do to a large degree that makes very
little sense is the use of focus groups,
so think about what a strange idea is
that we take 10 people who know
basically nothing about your project and
you put them in a room and you let them
talk for awhile and then you take the
whatever they came up with as a
consequence of these two hours of random
thinking and you base your strategy on
it to a large degree and,
and I,
I don't want to say that focus groups
are always useless and also
uninformative,
but I think that taking this data and
then realizing it as extensively as
companies do,
I think.
I think it's crazy in many ways and the
reason I think companies do it is
because when these people create a
sentence or an idea,
it's very easy to say,
joe focus group 17 said this and it can
help you create a form.
Formulate an idea around it.
When if you said 87 percent of the
people said x,
it just doesn't have a face.
It doesn't have a desire.
It's just not as concrete and therefore
people are not as excited about the,
about the notion.
So I think that focus group is
incredibly useful as a persuasive
attempt,
uh,
to,
to tell people what to do,
but as a way to find out information,
it's not as useful as people think it
is.
The other thing that really puzzles me
is that company is how little they
understand about how incentives really
work.
So the biggest expenditure for almost
any company is salaries.
And you ask people what do you know
about the relationship between salaries
and performance?
The answer is nothing.
Right?
And,
and the question is why don't they study
anything?
Why don't they study,
why don't they try different
performance,
different incentive level and see how it
influenced a performance.
And they often say,
well,
the law kind of low laws and if we have
pay some people one way and some another
way we might be sued.
And when the last two years with all
these questions about bonuses and so on,
I've gone to many companies and said,
why don't we at least do some surveys?
Why don't we at least see how happy
people are on the months when they give
them,
you give them the bonus and how
productive they are,
and the answer I got 100 percent of the
time is that people are really miserable
in bold decision and because of that
they don't want to ask them any more
questions and I said,
if people are miserable in bonuses and
shouldn't it mean that you should study
it,
understand it and try to prevent it from
next for next year and say,
well,
well not this year.
This year was really miserable.
Maybe next year come back to us next
year,
but if you think about.
It's really incredible.
Now how do companies decided about
compensation?
They look at what other companies are
doing and try to equate compensation to
what other companies are doing it,
but it's a place of the blind leading
the blind.
Right?
And then if we pay five percent more,
other people will start doing it.
But the real question is how do you pay
and how do you get people to care about
their work and become more productive
and be happier at their work?
And the answer is not simply that more
money is better,
more money can be part of the equation,
but it's also the question of how do you
give that money?
You give it a bonus to give it as a
fixed salary.
Do you give it as a part of the
benefits?
Maybe you give benefits for the gym.
Do you send people on vacation to the
Bahamas?
And it turns out that there are ways to
use money that he's cannot make the less
efficient,
but actually get people to be more
motivated,
caremore and actually become more
productive.